most people know the Hulk is a gigantic
green guy who's incredibly strong super
tough and can maybe jump really really
far pretty straightforward right but it
turns out that in the comics the Hulk
actually has a lot of weird bonus
abilities as well here's a look at some
superpowers most people don't know the
whole Cavs beyond sucker-punching that
is Hulk sees dead people weirdly enough
it turns out the Hulk can detect the
spectral realm and even interact with it
allowing him to see ghosts as well as
dr. Strange's astral form although it's
never been made official it's been
suggested that the Hulk gained the
ability to see ghosts because Bruce
Banner fears his abusive father might
haunt him being afraid of ghosts makes
sense since clearly the Hulk's got
nothing to fear in the physical world is
that where you go Hulk has brain shield
there's nothing worse for a superhero
than being mind-controlled by an evil
telepath or demon luckily for the Hulk
he's actually naturally resistant to
psychic attack in the comics while
disability doesn't have 100% success
rate it has allowed him to fight off
psychic intrusions from the likes of
xemnu mental low and even Professor X
why the Hulk is resistance of psychic
abilities is unclear though it might
have to do with his multiple personality
disorder still if you're going to mess
with the Hulk's brain your best bet is
just flying in his ear
Hulk phone home Bruce Banner may have
been born in Dayton Ohio but the Hulk
was created in New Mexico something he
has constantly reminded of thanks to a
powerful homing instinct that
continually draws him back to the
deserts of the southwest it's later
revealed by an evil future version of
the Hulk named maestro that his ghost is
what's been summoning Hulk to the bomb
site so that he can absorb enough gamma
radiation through Hulk's body to be
reborn seems legit Hulk absorb and expel
energy the Hulk was born when Bruce
Banner absorbed way too much gamma
radiation so it actually kind of makes
sense that the Hulk is able to absorb an
even control gamma energy to a limited
degree he fused this handy ability on
several occasions even deflecting gamma
rays like a mirror while battling the
Avengers don't mess with the Hulk Hulk
very very healthy like Wolverine the
Hulk has a superhuman healing factor
which allows him to recover from
injuries and fight off diseases but he's
also aided by that crazy gamma radiation
which tends to just flat-out kill off
any parasites or germs that are stupid
enough to attempt infecting the whole
aside from giving him a clean bill of
health his super immunity also helps the
Hulk detoxify when he's been poisoned
something Bruce probably appreciates
when he decides to tie one on the night
before sounds amazing he's also a huge
dork check sticker Hulk is super
adaptable if you've ever seen the Hulk
jump up out of Earth's atmosphere or
walk along the bottom of the ocean you
probably noticed that he has certain
advantages over normal people it's clear
that he doesn't need to breathe and is
impervious to the vacuum of space but
why well thanks to some research from
shield
we know that the Hulk's gamma mutation
allows him to further mutate and adapt
to any environment he's exposed to
probably explains how he managed to walk
away after this
Hulk has super breath everyone knows
about Superman in his superbreath but
did you know that the Hulk also has
lungs of steel not only does this make
him a hit at birthday parties it's also
a handy trick to use on enemies or even
on random forests like this one that the
Hulk flattened on a whim in Incredible
Hulk number 273 apparently the Hulk
isn't much of an environmentalist but he
is a pretty big blowhard Oh Reggie was
like smoldering for Hulk can punch their
time and space just how strong is the
Hulk well it turns out he's strong
enough to punch through dimensional
barriers and even destroy the entire
dimensions with a swing of his big dumb
fist not only that but in one story he
was able to punch his way through a time
storm and on another occasion he plugged
a black hole with his blood you might
say the Hulk has godlike powers except
well he's kind of in a class all his own
[Applause]
huge job thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]